[Music]
for our cancellation today we head up to
a ranch in montauk new york where horses
and obesity have combined to create a
perfect cancellation
storm perfect conditions for
cancellation nbc news has the important
story it says remy uh remy bader a tick
tock star known for her realistic
clothing haul videos
actually have to stop right there
because um we haven't even finished the
first sentence but
realistic clothing haul videos
i'm not sure what a clothing haul video
is i'm even less sure how such a video
could be unrealistic in the first place
do most tick tock stars in the clothing
hall genre use special effects or cgi is
she a pioneer of like gritty live-action
clothing haul videos these are questions
we don't have time to investigate
because there are larger problems to
deal with continuing remy barber bader a
tick-tock star known for her realistic
clothing haul videos claimed that during
a recent trip with other influencers a
ranch wouldn't allow her to ride their
horses due to her weight
bader who has more than two million
followers on tiktok was in montauk new
york with other influencers on a trip
organized by the company hampton water
wine over the weekend when she said she
was turned away
now i'm imagining being stuck on a
camping trip or a hiking trip with
tick-tock influencers organized by a
company called hampton water wine and
i'm just filled with dread and despair
at the thought of it
i'd probably just steal one of the
horses and ride off into the sunset
never to be seen again that is assuming
all the horses hadn't been crushed to
death already because that's what this
woman apparently feels she has the right
to do to horses reading more it says in
her initial tic toc post on saturday
bader shared a video of the ranch with
the text over it saying
shout out to deep hollow ranch and
montauk for making me leave because i
weigh over 240 pounds
videos received over 1.5 million views
the caption reads i've rode horses
before and i've never had an issue
she asked them to advertise on their
signs in the future
yes they ought to advertise that on
their signs
this is their fault for not putting
something on their signs indicating that
they'd prefer if their horse's spines
were left intact
because of this oversight remy felt
entitled to publicly bash this small
business as a result the company is now
being flooded with negative yelp reviews
which by the way is a potentially fatal
blow to any business of this size
after launching this attack and
receiving blowback in her own direction
she then claimed that her beef isn't
with the weight limit itself but with
the abrupt and insulting way in which
she was informed of the weight limit
it's not what they said but how they
said it she now claims
and for its part the ranch initially had
no comment instead a teenage employee
took it upon himself to issue his own
rebuttal to this woman and um i'll just
say that his
his pr skills could use a little bit of
work let's watch
[Laughter]
when you're not a fat you can ride a
deep ball ranch
well
you know that was rude certainly and the
video's been deleted as you'd expect the
ranch has apologized for it and uh
we could probably assume the kid was
fired but remy was determined to get the
last word the next day she clapped back
as the kids say with this rebuttal
um if you don't like me that's fine
but
you know
watch him
out two million view uh followers on
that account
in summary a lot of very stupid people
are involved in this story as is so
often the case for the things we talk
about during this segment and during
every other segment of the show but
there are a couple of points i think to
be made here the first is that not every
personal gripe needs to be presented to
the entire world
so let's just pretend for a moment that
remy was completely polite and
accommodating maybe she didn't know that
horses have weight limits maybe she
thought that horses have spines made of
reinforced steel and she just didn't
realize that this was a thing and maybe
she was very understanding when they
informed her of this matter and only
became upset because they were rude and
insulting about it even if that's the
case
why does the world need to be involved
in this dispute why why
would you want the world to be involved
aren't you embarrassed that you were
turned away from a horse ranch because
you exceed the weight limit
if that were me i would go home and pray
that nobody posts anything about the
incident online i certainly wouldn't be
posting about it myself and tell people
about it
but as much as people these days pretend
to care so much about privacy
like we've never talked about privacy as
much as we do in in our society
yet the fact is that most people want
anything but privacy in fact most people
fear privacy
privacy to them is akin to annihilation
annihilation
if they don't post everything online
they'll cease to be they think
they have an answer to the old tree
falling in a forest question if nobody
hears it it doesn't make a sound that's
their opinion just as if nobody knows
about every single thing that's
happening to them
they don't exist
that's why people will willingly post
the sorts of things that people of
previous generations would have died to
keep out of public view
there are no boundaries
no shame especially for influencers
whose livelihood depends on making a
spectacle and controversy out of
everything that happens to them
but of course i don't buy that this
person was polite and reasonable and
only upset because of the rudeness of
the staff at the ranch pretty clear at
least initially that she was simply mad
that they wouldn't let her ride the
horses from her perspective it is well
worth sacrificing the physical
well-being of a horse in order to
protect her own emotional well-being
as ben shapiro pointed out in his
reaction to the story these are the
wages of expressive individualism
of course expressive individualism is
the defining philosophy of the modern
age we talk about it all the time on
this show even if not by that name it's
what carl truman elucidates so
brilliantly in his book the rise and
triumph of the modern self he also talks
about it in my film what is a woman
according to expressive individualism
a person is totally defined by
his psychological state
his feelings his self-perception
the primary point of life really the
only point is to protect and affirm and
reinforce
that psychological state lives are lived
inwardly
everybody is looking back within
themselves all the time reflecting
constantly on their own inner experience
all that matters is the inner experience
whatever must be done to improve that
experience the one felt inside the one
perceived by the mind
even if it not always reflected in
reality doesn't matter whatever must be
done for its sake
should be done that's all
all that matters to the expressive
individual is their own psychological
comfort
to live authentically is to live in a
way that expresses their current
psychological state and makes them feel
better about it
and if that means crushing a horse it
means crushing a horse
yes you know horses have weight limits
in physical reality but in the mind of
this plus-sized rider on the saddle
there is no weight limit they can do
anything that anybody else can do
that's how they perceive the world and
themselves then everybody else's job is
to conform to that perception
this mentality obviously has
consequences far far beyond potential
spinal injuries to horses but you know
that is one of the that's collateral
damage there's a lot of collateral
damage left behind as the expressive
individual goes about her life making
herself feel better about herself and
never worrying about anything else least
of all horses
and that is why she is today finally
canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated
you